so you saying you've been through the
audition Miller or processed so many
times do you have something in place
that protects you inside every time you
go on an audition because such a you
know it could go so many ways I just
forget about it
basically I'll go and I will not
remember the audition after I mean I'll
remember it immediately after like dead
together bad and often that is
conversely correct or like their times
are have thighs it's awful and I get the
job or times with odds did great don't
get a callback
but like most the time within like a day
someone will really have to remind me of
what I just a bit cuz I'm sort of just
like you get forget about it forget
about it until they tell you you did you
got the callback heard they tell you you
did something good otherwise you'll just
it'll just hurt you
like with a pilot process for and that's
the hardest thing like pilot process for
television like you'll go seven eight
times for these auditions over and over
again you'll go and meet with lawyers to
sign contracts and things and then nope
and then it's like oh you're tool poor
we thought it blonde or something like
that or like we're gonna start from the
beginning we're going to change the
character or the character doesn't exist
there's like so many things that you
can't worry about it
cuz if you worry about it too much it'll
just do you know like destroy yourself
like oh what I do when you just gotta be
yourself
you just got to do it you got to do what
you do best and that's not gonna be for
everything that's gonna be for most
things but if you do it long enough
hopefully you can finish that and people
will see that's good
you